hallo meine lieben mein name ist pokémon
trainer 31 und ich möchte euch ganz
gerne zu einer neuen map begrüßen und zu
spielen wie heute dicklicher zwei ich
hab mir vor einigen tagen schon mal
meinem kanal ok alles da leute ich bin
es wieder und wir spielen heute der
hatte pokémon trainer 31 1 342 wie auch
immer pokémon trainer hatte recht ich
bin heute der gletscher 2
ich habe schon mal in der bildschirm web
hochgeladen die hieß sie minecraft
glitches und bevor wir loslegen ich habe
die mir vor zwei tagen gefährt beim
amerikanischen youtuber gesehen und
dachten wir suchen okay geil masse das
hatte vorerst gestern noch die idee
dieses computer video zu bringen und
dann hat gestern fiel die mehr baustart
weil die wahrscheinlich auch von ihm
gesehen hat ein paar von euch haben die
fed zum beispiel gesehen an alle die die
schon gesehen haben sorry weil ich den
ersten mal gespielt hat bräuchten
zweiten unbedingt nochmal spielen ich
hoffe ihr versteht das was sind denn die
regeln hier
okay das ist der typische sound man
allein schon die grünen augen
alles klar also dicke teenager habe ich
grade mal nachgeschaut und weil die
regeln hier irgendwie nicht stehen am
anfang
ich habe nicht die irgendwie kann ich
das hier gerade nicht um schüler
deswegen probleme von unser glück sollte
so funktionieren klicks ein blau statt
luft wie hand liebevoll ist okay da ist
ein baum ja dann lena 5
so leute ich jetzt gerade am schnitt und
bevor das video anfängt eine kurze
ankündigung der zweite teil von the
witcher war deutlich deutlich schwerer
als erste deswegen gab es einige level
wo ich einfach nicht geschafft habe ich
insgesamt jetzt wirklich probiert eine
stunde 20 für die map gebraucht für eine
map die eigentlich zehn bis 15 minuten
angeblich dauern soll
das heißt ich hab's probiert teilweise
zum einfachen geklappt deswegen muss sie
teilweise kontingentwechseln damit ich
selbst noch spaß beim meppen jeder
nachher beim schauen auch spaß an abgabe
versteht das und jetzt film ab start
okay ich kann meinen game mode nicht
ändern und ich bin im game mode 1 ok
als ob also das ding einfach
überschrieben kann sie können wieder
hochfahren
was treibt uns überhaupt gerade an den
berg hoch ich werde einfach ich hab kein
morgen fährt
wir müssen irgendwie dichter schon also
denke ich einfach mal wie mit dem boot
in diesem trick jetzt aussteigen hier
und ja sehr nah ist ok alles klar nehme
somit und gönnen uns den ersten check
point weiter geht's level nummer zwei
ist etwa noch mal ein bett hier drin
wenn wir hier eine ändert ruhe
jetzt muss man mal gucken okay er geht
mit dem deal mit den liliana erklärte
hoch und jetzt die frage wo ist
eigentlich dieses goldene plättchen mal
gucken wo könnte die ist dass die
goldene jazz plate nein wo ist sie denn
also macht peripherie wo kann die sein
hier muss ja da hinten sicher etwas
goldenes tänzen oder ssd können wir hier
über ja wenn wir hier über ok es ist ein
goldener blog aber okay erstmal erste
frage überhaupt wo ist überhaupt die
goldene peitsche brett sechs stunden
später kommt überhaupt nicht weiter und
ich habe mir einen kleinen tipp
eingeholt scheinbar hier scheinbar ist
hier hinter eine doppel test und dann
wenn man hier draufklicken auf das ding
dazwischen und das ist ein holzblock wir
sehen es ist ein holzblock kommen aus
irgendeinem grund an die kiste dahinter
und kann diese pressure plate die ihr so
komischen die in der gegend hängt da
rausnehmen da wäre ich in meinem leben
nicht draufgekommen leute hier sehen wir
übrigens auch dass die nur auf einem
gold verziert werden kann und den gott
dazu haben natürlich schon gefunden er
war da oben wenn ihr irgendetwas es war
kindes gerne mal in die kommentare
schreiben weil ich hab keine ok
passieren und ab geht's ins nächste
level dms ist ein eisbär hey leute ich
hab gerade eine ewigkeit gebraucht um
herauszufinden wie ich jetzt hier in den
gamer 0 rein komme bei dem es eigentlich
zugelassen hat dafür muss ich auch ein
bisschen googeln aber ok ich muss sagen
jetzt die schildchen grafischen prestige
tiefpreis dazwischen gehen sondern
braucht man eigentlich eine angenehme
okay ich nehme erst mal ein preis pro a
wie angeln ist der preis
als ob da drin eine goldene peitsche
schwingt kann man die angeln
wir kriegen sich raus das lässt sich
nicht an ein etf ist das richtig so das
ist die analyse wurde es jetzt kommen
sie raus gezogen
ok alles klar also gut jetzt müssen wir
irgendwie der hochkommen
das sieht aus als wäre das auf jeden
fall einen blog auf dem man drauf
springen kann
herr den sprung kann man locker schaffen
das muss doch gehen
jetzt haben wir es okay sehr schön und
jetzt ist die frage wie jetzt von hier
aus weiter also ich glaube es ist kein
zufall dass man jetzt hier um die ecke
kommen konnte
jetzt müssen wir das scheinbar auf den
sound von dem zaun darüber äußerst nicht
so laut
ach was hier ist man sich bei blog.de
scheinbar existierte jetzt können wir
hier rum
das sieht gut aus das hier ist ganz
schön tricky da werden die jump skills
durchaus gefordert habe ich das gefühl
wenn wir jetzt hier von dem unteren
dingen darauf da beamten dann klappt das
ist das hier ist angeblich möglich ja
wahrscheinlich legal
ok
okay das sieht aus als wird das zu
bedauern
ich schaffe einfach dass ich hoffe dass
dann nicht ich habe es jetzt locker frau
hat mich nicht wie lange ich habe es
zehn 15 minuten ausprobiert ich krieg
sich gebacken der glitch an sich den
haben wir eigentlich schon geschafft
hätte zwar glaube ich dass es das mit
der angel das ding herausgeholt haben
deswegen müssen wir jetzt einfach mal
ganz ehrlich und offen die eher
entspannt ding demut 1 rein klatschen
das jump man so tricky alter allein das
ding da unten schon echt schwierig dann
okay das hier ist sie das hier geht das
hier doch das ging jetzt auch ja und das
dann wieder mega tricky und so geht das
glaube ich so geht das weiter
das ist so mega trick das ist was für
ein höllisches jump'n'run man leute ich
denke es macht mehr sinn dass ich jetzt
hier einfach quasi ja auch mal ehrlich
mit euch aber ihr hoch legen macht ja
auch nicht so viel sinn wenn ich jetzt
die mega um frust und hätte ich es
einfach nicht gebacken bekommen hier
wurden schlecht tag erwägen wieder ein
game 2 und umgebracht
moment mal wenn wir raus laufen da
drüben haben wir direkt weil sie die
goldenstedter sie müssen einfach nur
über diese zeilen und die frage ist wie
geht das
okay ist es geht wie strange
wieso backen wir denn da so drin was ist
das denn
okay wir haben irgendwie leid reisters
elettra an das skaten flügel irgendwie
dazu bei dass wir schaffen was war dass
ich das gemacht
ok mit dem editor können wir als
irgendwie viel früher banken gebe mir
einfach dass das passiert was das ok die
damit man sich einfach so uns fallen
lassen einander gegengesteuert wenn es
hier einfach so machen dann kommen wir
da glaub ich nicht drüber
das glück ist mir irgendwie nicht so
hold leute 2000 jahre später es wenig
leute es will pfizer nicht diese meppen
macht mich fertig ohne witz und käse und
wie habe ich grade eben darüber
geschafft ich habe keine chance sich
hänger wieder solar momentan okay leute
ich will wirken die spaßbremse sein aber
ich habe auch etwa dieses level wieder
15 minuten braucht und wenn bei zwei von
vier also die ersten beiden habe ich
geschafft und löschen aber die anderen
beiden keine ahnung es funktioniert
einfach überhaupt nicht aber ich bin
ehrlich zu euch hier willst einfach
irgendwie nicht zu funktionieren ich
weiß nicht wie es gemacht habe ich habe
ganze darum probiert alles möglich
die map gibt uns ganz schön den rest das
muss man einfach so sagen nicht schlecht
hut ab ist die dinger sind echt heftig
so was haben wir hier als üblich sind
ende mäßig aus die verstecken auch ganz
gerne mal sachen als es nur eine
wirtschafts sondern auch ein rätsel
eigentlich war ich extrem viel versteckt
wird
was können wir mit diesem ding machen
mit diesem entstand ok abbauen auf jeden
fall nicht kümmern zu einem
durchpeitschen
gibt es da drin eventuell dann die lang
ersehnte goldene pressure play die wir
so dringend brauchen für das ding
draußen wenn es mal gucken wo ist denn
überhaupt die goldenen tablett wo haben
sie die versteckt
wenn man ihm entrichten eingang hier
rein geht es einfach zwei ändern
drachenköpfe die irgendwas vor sich in
der 10
man muss jedoch vor klar okay was ist
wenn man vielleicht von hier das ding
macht anspringen passiert da irgendwas
wir können auf jeden fall nicht aufs
dach drauf die allerstädter reichen
nicht aus dann muss das irgendwie da
vorne durchgehen was als ob kann man
einfach durch nicole wtf von euch das an
leute man muss einfach man kann einfach
mit nieten dadurch laufe das gibt's ja
nicht alles gesehen aber jetzt jetzt
jetzt einfach dran laufen nicht mehr
springen oder von selbst bringt dran
laufen einfach sinken
lg peter hier oben könnt einfach so
drauf und dann seid ihr dran und können
wir dann brauchst in den ende lachen
ok man kann schon mal auf dem bett
aufstehen
danke dir hier rüber und da unten ist
schon mal eine kiste alles klar
ok da ist das ding und wir haben auch
unsere ender perlen mit dem wir einfach
die sie raus können ganz komfortabel
zack nach draußen und wir können das
ding wahrscheinlich wieder auf dem gold
produzieren genauso wie wir es kennen
packen sie drauf und dann ist das ding
auch geschafft und
ok eichenholz boot wurde gedroppt so auf
pascal mit dem boot hermachen
okay gut dann vielleicht also hier
können auf dem fall dran
sowas ist in den kisten dran jede menge
eichenholz boote alles klar
hier noch mehr können fechtig platzieren
dann einsteigen und auf der andern seite
aussteigen jawohl das geht easy alter
trotzdem hätte ich bestimmt nur fest ich
glaube ich bin genau im glas kommt man
hier kann man wirklich mal raus es sieht
so aus als komme hier nicht mehr
rauskommt sagt dir und bitte einfach
nach vorn vom aussteigen kann
und wieder ein glas hey das kann nicht
der sinn der sache sein und wie kommen
wir da nicht raus
okay das level das level ist verpackt da
muss man die glaswand der plan gut das
level ein bisschen verpackt aber wir
haben auf jeden fall den match mit dem
boden gut bewältigt ich sagen und jetzt
geht es weiter mit dem nächsten
redstone kisten teichen heiß ist kann
schon mal nicht schaden das mitzunehmen
jede menge pfeile
die vielen jahren noch mit ok da unten
ist ein okay okay okay okay okay okay
ich glaub ich kann mir schon denken in
welche richtung das gehen soll
sollen wir vielleicht einfach da unten
im bogen kräften könnte das der die
sache sein das konzil von bodenkräften
müssen wir haben uns reden wir haben
unsere pfeile vor allen dingen auch und
dann einfach hier drüben quasi von oben
auf die presche plate schießen und er
quasi durch einen bogenschuss die
forscher fällt auslösen
wovon der ist gar nicht mal so easy ja
ja bis mehr nach vorne aber nicht so
weit ganz schön schwer die pfeile auf so
eine kurze distanzen basieren auf mich
selbst ja wohl um gold
oh mein gott
was alter ich hab kein scheiß eine
stunde 20 aufgenommen wir verdanken es
schon soweit wir sehen uns morgen im
neuen video wieder haut rein macht gut
und ja